okay everybody I'm so excited today
because Mary Holland is back on the show
I last talked to her for the woman in
the house across the street from the
girl in the window and that's the last
time I've ever sang that title so I'm
excited about that uh but she is
promoting self-reliance which she stars
and she on Hulu today how you doing
today Mary I'm great how are you Steve
good I'm so excited to talk to you again
um me too yeah and I really love this
film and I'm it's so exciting today's
opening day so everyone's seeing
it yeah and I love this character Amy
you play but people see she's like
Tommy's tough love sister here so do you
find yourself someone who gives a lot of
tough love in Life or ises that kind of
make you uncomfortable absolutely not uh
it does make me
uncomfortable um I'm more likely to
receive tough love than I am to give it
but that made stepping into this
character uh very cathartic for me
because uh because it was nice to be
that that sort of that kind of role in
somebody's life yeah and it just makes
it that much more impressive how you
play it that it's probably something
more foreign to you so I like that and
uh was there anything in this script
that stuck out to you that made you want
to do it I love the script so much I'm
first of all I'm I'm such a massive Jake
Johnson fan and I think he's he's
totally brilliant he's such a brilliant
actor and and writer and he had such a
vision for this movie as a director uh I
remember when I auditioned for him he
was so clear about what who this
character was how what her function was
in the family and who she was to Tommy
the main character and um I thought the
script the thing as a whole I thought
was so it pulled me in immediately but
the the premise of it I think is so
clever it's such an interesting and
unique way to explore this this idea of
connection and of uh you know having to
forge relationships in the truly life or
death death situation yeah and I like
you point out it being unique and I like
you highlight that word relationships
how important that is just with scripts
and you being a great writer yourself
what are some red flags that might stick
out to you when reading a script that
would make you like not want to do a
part is there anything that would just
jump off I'm not doing
this uh oh gosh that's I mean I feel
like if it's I mean if it if the if a
character is
like sort of not um if there's no reason
for a character's Behavior like if
there's no kind of emotional through
line that that's definitely a some a red
flag might be too strong a term but it's
definitely something that I would want
to dig into a little bit because uh uh
I've been very lucky so far to to only
get to do projects where all the
characters are very three-dimensional
and thought through and and the
directors are super intentional and the
writers yeah so yeah know I like that
and there's like a seal of like if Mary
Holland's in it it should be at least
pretty good so there's not like oh she's
not no for for sure I'm not just saying
that and um it's interesting I
interviewed Emily Hampshire sure
yesterday and I want your take on this
because I asked her this question and I
want to know why your character was
named Amy and she was Mary and did you
at least fight for to be Mary was it
confusing because she says it was very
confusing it wasn't confusing to me I I
think the characters were so distinct in
my mind that it's almost like Emily's
Mary was a totally separate Mary than me
Mary so it didn't it didn't confuse me
at all like when when she was called
Mary I was like oh yeah that's Mary like
I didn't I didn't have the instinct to
respond to it because because her
character was just so specific and
distinct um and I did not campaign for
Amy to be married I felt I felt Amy was
Amy and you know her her name starts
with the first letter of the alphabet
she is the alpha in the family I love it
tracks it tracks yeah I like that that
importance to the name that that's a
great answer um yeah I feel more bad for
Emily no because she's still confused
out there about it but I poor Emily poor
Emily but I also want to bring up to I
loved your performance in senior year
and I loved it because it was I was
surprised how dramatic it was it was a
dramatic performance to me in in a funny
movie but um I was blown away by it so
I'm wondering are you open to doing more
like straight dramatic roles is that a
yes yes Steve I'm desperate
too uh I would love it I would be I
would be Beyond thrilled to get that
opportunity yeah and thank you so much
for that yeah no we would love it the
fans because I did not expect that when
I was watching that movie and I was like
this aming so it makes me excited for
the future for Mary Holland and it's
cool to hear you you actually want to do
it too yeah Chom
yeah notice people notice let it be
known Let It Be
know um now this is cool too I I think I
told you in my last interview but I
loved happiest season um which you
worked on with CLA Duval so are there
still plans for you both to unite for a
TV series day job is I don't even if
that's the right title at this point
yeah yeah the title ort of a work in
progress we we definitely uh hope to get
to uh manifest that at some point it's
sort of you know with with the last few
years and the strikes everything's kind
of um up in the air a bit so so I'm not
sure specifically how it's going to come
together or when but I we both really
want it and hope to make it do you when
you when you work with her too I'm
wondering do you find a lot of like pros
about about writing with somebody
compared to when you write alone is is
there something you kind of value with
that totally I I actually have a really
hard time writing on my own and I it
probably does stem from coming from an
improv background where it is that's
such an ensemble craft and you you can't
build it alone you have to build it with
other people and so um I find it very
helpful to collaborate because it's it's
two brains instead of just one and and
there's things also I find that my
partner thinks of that I would never
think of or or feedback they have on an
on an idea I have that I didn't consider
so I just feel like it's so beneficial
so it sounds like you like to
collaborate too like you don't feel like
oh this is my idea we're doing it like
you're no okay no I'm like the the more
the marrier let's let's fill this
kitchen with Cooks I love it love it um
now I also see correct me if wrong that
you'll be in a film night with Amy
Adams yeah is that finished filming is
that still happening or yeah we we have
finished filming that I'm not sure the
details on when that's coming out or or
how but uh the filming of it was a
truly wonderful experience I Amy Adams
is somebody I have looked up to my
entire life it feels like yeah yeah um I
remember watching her in drop dead
gorgeous and being like who
is this person and then of course she
you know became a superstar and so it's
been that was a huge honor to get to
work with her on that that's awesome so
I hope you were in her ear like Amy I
want to do dramatic roles get me the
dramatic yeah I grabbed her by the
caller and I said help
me but is that movie that's gonna is
that like a horror comedy or just
straight comedy or no I that that is
definitely more more dramatic um all
right sort of exploring motherhood and
exploring the the darker aspects of you
know the struggle that I think a lot of
a lot of parents go through so um so
yeah I'm excited for for everyone to see
it yeah I'm pumped that that sounds like
an awesome cast and um I want to say too
because I kind of alluded to this before
but from just people in my circle who
love TV and film um I feel like you're
right now a person that people would
watch cuz you're in it like
I would watch you do laundry right I'm
serious when I say that so um you didn't
bring laund it's not that exciting I
didn't I didn't it's really not you
would be
disappointing but but me telling you
that does that I don't know if you're s
aware of that or not but does that add a
pressure to you like maybe when you're
on set like oh my God I gotta I got to
bring it again I've been bringing it but
do is there pressure there no it's I I I
mean yes to you definitely want to
deliver and you want to uh hold you want
to make sure that you're um pulling your
weight along with everyone else in the
production like you want to like you
know be reliable and be be sort of what
you were hired to do but but at the same
time I'm I'm so grateful to to get to do
it and so I love doing it so much that
the pressure is kind of an after that's
sort of on the back burner as opposed to
the joy of getting to do it oh that's
great and yeah I mean it's awesome your
pors always come off Natural and I'm
really excited for people to see you uh
in self-reliance is on Hulu today Mary's
great to talk to again and I hope see
you in the future one day yeah I hope so